good morning belief nation today's
message is don't care what they say over
you natalie portman it's very hard to
separate the you know the things that
other people want for you the values
that society tells you you're supposed
to go after and the things that are
really meaningful for you you know I
definitely grew up being linked got to
get good grades I've got to get a good
job I've got it you know get married at
a certain point I've got it you know you
feel like there's these things that
you're supposed to do and that you're
you have to do and then it's an amazing
shift I'm sure many of you get have
gotten there you know or will get there
if you haven't but it's an amazing thing
when one day you're just like oh this is
what is important for me and I don't
care what they say I don't care why you
know why other people think I'm doing it
or not doing it the rest is sort of ego
you know I love this message and I I
don't think most people get to that
point I think it's great that Natalie
has gotten there but I don't think most
people do I think most people live their
entire lives worried about what they
think right and we may have these
moments if I call the moments of
boldness where you wake up and you're
you have some idea and for some reason
you believe in it and you're super
confident and you think you can make it
happen and you have the abilities and
you're super pumped up and excited and
ready to go off and tackle it and then
what do you do you tell your friends you
tell your parents you tell your siblings
you tell the people in your class you
tell somebody in your community and how
often how often is the immediate
reaction that's an amazing idea how can
I help you do it usually the reaction is
oh yeah well that's not gonna work
because of this and have you thought
about that and like well you don't have
the skills to do that and it's do poking
all the holes in
client and what does that do to you it
deflates you right like when everybody
around you is telling you can't do it it
it it's really really hard to stand up
and say no I'm going to make it happen
and I think that's the unfortunate
circumstance and most people are in and
then you never go off and realize the
dream life that you want to build for
yourself and instead you live your
entire life according to other people's
opinions values never really stepping up
to do your own thing and I think the way
to change that is to change the day
right change the day change the people
that you are surrounding yourself with
changes people that you bounce ideas off
of because as long as you hang around
these people with these values they're
gonna continue to pull you down where if
you change the day and even if that's
watching these videos right even if
that's watching YouTube with people who
inspire you and build you up that's the
new day for you and you can think about
Natalie Portman or Oprah Winfrey or some
other entrepreneur that you look up to
and say they can do it I can do it too
and when you change the Veii and you
start believing yourself that's when the
magic starts to happen
so the question today today is I'm
curious about the people in your life do
they build you up and help you become
the best version of yourself
or do they drag you down and try to make
you live their life leave it in the
comments below
super curious to find out thank you guys
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events press